Dow started when he was 36 36 imagine
that in the crazy part is you were one
of his original mentors and the guy that
said I'll [ __ ] teach you because
everybody else would you're too [ __ ]
old yeah
specifically Ric Flair Ric Flair told
him Dallas you've been a manager you do
this well you do that well but in the 36
get a grip on you know you're too
[ __ ] old to start and when Dallas
told me that I'm like [ __ ] man if it
surgeries it really your dream he says
my [ __ ] dream man I want it [ __ ] it
I'll teach him and that's why I started
I moved in with him and then we had the
infamous snake accident in his house
what was the infamous snake hisses oh I
got busy with a girlfriend and forgot
what I was doing upstairs I was washing
the snake off and Mac downstairs to
check on her and she caught me by
surprise and raped me oh my god I forgot
the snake upstairs ooh
so I ran back upstairs realized it been
two and a half hours and Dallas is just
coming over his bedroom he's like what
the [ __ ] you been in the shower the
whole time I'm like yeah I just uh yeah
I'm sweaty look at me no I'm in the
shower yeah man mistake was in there
I'll get my shaver get right out you'll
watch leave the show Dallas I was
watching some soap out man [ __ ] get a
grip man leave me alone so I go a tear
plugin [ __ ] its name oh my god I can't
find the [ __ ] snake he's not in here
oh my god which kind of snake is this is
a Cobra he had had three cats oh no oh
no so I started looking for it then I
had to fess up the Dallas what was going
like dude dude dude dude yeah you gotta
find that [ __ ] my wife will be
home in 20 minutes like what holy [ __ ]
you know I'll fight any man but [ __ ]
woman hell no they will [ __ ] you up and
I run from women they [ __ ] you up and
they wait to your sleep and [ __ ] [ __ ] em
[ __ ] you up again because we have dicks
we think you know they love me cuz of my
dick or whatever and giving in cuz
they're going home on
so much then you fall asleep actuator
actually here yo whoa I've been married
your experience is very different than
mine
well I've had three successful marriages
nobody died I did 13 years my first wife
13 years with my second wife four months
with my third so I'm getting better
what but it sounds like you're talking
about prison I did 13 years this is
about marriage how's it 13 years that's
like Samuel s in an ad said goes that
goes back to my experience right you
know my experience is unfortunate
because what I've been through I let a
woman get this close to me we're about
to get started getting real which is
what I really want but then I got to
push it back cuz Brian can handle it I
want to get back to this but I wonder
what happened to the cats
okay well long story short I couldn't
find him this no long as long as I was
there how much well right before she got
home I thought I would do the man thing
and get my car and run that's what I did
that is what he did [ __ ] I had a
slick [ __ ] 84 Corvette that I knew
would not look good with high heels
going up and down right cuz that [ __ ] a
wonderful lady she was she was leaving
[ __ ] up she's gonna [ __ ] everybody
right and if I'm not sleeping with you
you're not gonna talk [ __ ] like that to
me right you know that's true always
good if I'm sleeping with you but that
was it I had to leave I came back two
days later in my defense
two days later okay and when I got there
I see all these workmen carrying sheets
of sheetrock sheetrock yeah I'm like
what the [ __ ]
and then Dallas had told me they were
gonna do some remodeling downstairs oh
they're working on my [ __ ] room right
he's like dude 15 minutes package it and
go what you got to get out
one little snake and I've got to go
that's really [ __ ] Dallas
and yeah they couldn't find the snake
either so they wound up calling some
people professional and the only way
they found it was by carrying out
several walls and they finally can pound
it or the walls what did it do climb an
event it got in the bed wherever I don't
know and got into the wall and flapped
up [ __ ] and they had to follow it
through the house how did they find it
by running out of walls geez Wow right
after they were quite upset
exactly so I have my kitchen worked on
once and after they sealed the the
drywall in the back I heard no cat so uh
my cat spaz I was like spaz she's like
[ __ ] I'm like she's in the [ __ ] wall
so I did go get a hammer and I had a
claw up in the wall and then pull her
out covered in [ __ ] that's where they
get the music boom boom and sweet cat
has that happen 19 years Wow yeah let me
tell you here I am in Australia this is
like 1993 or four and there's a Japanese
superstar named thunder just like mm-hmm
I mean just top of the top brother so
he's along to her witness no problem but
first night he's in was we'd already
been there two nights and these people
come in these Japs come in and they
start for gonna yeah yeah in Japanese to
this other guy in English transferred in
boom boom bottom line is he will not
stay in the same [ __ ] dress murmurs
Jake he's terrified of snakes dude I'm
not gonna get it on him no doesn't
matter he doesn't even think he should
be here because of Jake okay [ __ ] him
let him go where everyone I'm Gibbs you
know I told you I wouldn't get it on you
if my words not good enough [ __ ] off so
he goes and gets another dressing room
on the other side of these Coliseum long
ways across there he wrestles goes into
shower comes out from the shower he's
drying off he looks up in the mirror and
in the mirror he can see a pipe of cobra
he's come up
out of the toilet it was looking around
the room and the rest of him still on
the toilet and then he goes back down he
screams he runs across the [ __ ]
building nude got everybody's attention
the police get involved he comes down to
Jake where's your [ __ ] snake oh my I
really can't find it so he gotten out of
my locker room and went into the toilet
and took off and come up and that toilet
over there that's [ __ ] guy got on a
[ __ ] airplane that night and went the
[ __ ] home imagine the sense that he was
scared as I read it and then went and
found out the place where there was the
mostly one yeah yeah I wonder if that of
us in it I mean it only makes thank you
thank you since your that's they would
go after prey animals right prey armored
animals are terrified of them they
probably have a sense of fear if you the
[ __ ] toilet you imagine that goes
through the toilet I mean I still have
horror stories and bad memories of
sitting on a toilet in a snake just by
claiming the balls and mass happen you
know buddy I had those [ __ ] dreams
come to me because the snakes all those
[ __ ] years especially after that no
one would travel that way again how'd
you get the snake back I didn't I left
him over there and [ __ ] in Australia
sorry now he's taking over the country
Jesus Christ where's that [ __ ] snake
yeah it's in Melbourne that's where I
left him how long do those things live a
long time like how long 30 years 30
years so it's probably still alive